we've seen paper pump liquid containers
before usually in a hospital bed now
Jim's long craft has developed the
concept internal ocean friendly
alternative to the plastic bottle so
what we do is we submerge the mold into
the paper pulp slurry just for a few
seconds and this is how they come out of
the mold
we then line it on the inside with this
our secret solution to make it
watertight if this should end up in the
ocean this is what happens once
separated the paper pulp and lining
break down and can be eaten by fish and
bacteria what's new is the waterproof
lining made from natural products we
turn to nature to see what was
waterproof in nature rather than coming
up with some new synthetic lab-grown bio
plastic or anything we just turned to
nature when that is waterproof in nature
we can use that we can utilize it
funding from Sky Ocean ventures we'll
take the bottle idea to its next phase
of development it will also benefit the
company behind new biodegradable sachets
skipping rock slab made the edible
packets tested at the London hang me
half marathon they contained water and
condiments that might otherwise have
been given out in plastic bottles each
year around 480 billion plastic bottles
are solved globally now around 1 million
every minute but less than 50% of them
are collected for recycling and only 7%
are turned into new bottles we've got a
man-made problem right and we need a a
man-made solution to that problem now of
course we can pick it up from from the
beach but that doesn't stop plastics
getting put into the ocean in the first
place we can try and sweep it up from
the ocean but that doesn't get it put
into the ocean in the first place either
in a world increasingly sold on the idea
of change that exists the ideas to make
change happen James Matthews Sky News in
Kirk Cody